Before I implement the method, I'm going to write the tester. There are
multiple ways you could do this, but there are also a lot of ways that look
similar and don't work. Here's the way I came up with. First, it checks to see
if the kitten is more than 6 months. If so, we know that we want to return
cute. Now, if the kitten is not more than 6 months, but is 2 or more months.
Then the kitten is super cute. This condition is only checked if this condition
already failed. This whole piece of code is under the else clause for the first
if. Now if both of these conditions are false. Then we end up in the last else
clause. This catches everything that doesn't satisfy one of the first two
conditions. So, if the kitten's not older than 6 months, and is not 2 months or
older. Then it's younger than two months, and so it's not cute yet. Let's check
that this works. Okay, it looks like these match, they match, match, match and
match. So, we're good. We could change this code slightly by adding another
condition here. The code will still work modified this way, but it's considered
bad form. If you decide to modify the 2 months threshold. You now have to
change it in two places instead of just one. Also, if you don't understand the
condition right, or just make a little error, there could be cases that you
miss and don't handle at all. So, don't add an if condition here. That would be
a bug. What if we changed the order of these checks? So, I take months greater
than 6 and put it here. Months greater than or equal to 2, here, and then,
change the return values to match. Do you think this still works? let's try it.
It looks like it's wrong for the first case. These cases are okay and this one
is, but it looks like there aren't any cute kittens anymore. Only super cute
ones and not so cute ones. A kitten with eight months will do the first check
and find that it's true and return super cute, without ever testing to see if
it's more than six months, as well. No matter what number months starts out as,
this piece of code, here, will never run. That's a bug.